let's go to Carolyn from Utah Carolyn
from Utah welcome to the David packman
show what's on your mind today what can
I do for you
Carolyn from Utah you've been invited to
join welcome can you hear me yes I can
okay
great um I've been a long time listener
now this is a question okay I'm from
Utah like I like you said um we have a
Republican Governor
um box it's more of a Midstream
mainstream Republican he's not too far
to the left or too far to the right but
um he had uh
nominated a democratic person to go to
our environmental Council or whatever
and um the Republican
the people who would approve this
nomination of course put it down they
said no she can't be on the committee
now my question has to do with
um
the fact that the Republicans for so
long
let this information rule in regards to
climate change and things like that and
um in particular the way the Democrats
act so now some of these mainstream
Republicans
are trying to of course make a
turnaround
and when they realized they went too far
is there any way that you think that
they can pull back
the Republican Party sort of I don't
know I I'm worried about Civil War thing
but short of civil war is there any way
that we can pull back
the people that are
so far glad they can't understand reason
and logic
so Carolyn I apologize a lot of the
first stuff you said I did not Carolyn a
lot of the first stuff you said I didn't
really understand and you also had a
couple of audio glitches in there but
but what I think you're asking me is is
there any way to pull extremist
Republicans who are in in Fantasyland
kind of back to reality is that
generally your question
yeah but um in particular if there's any
way well for the mainstream Republicans
to do it I don't think we have any
chance oh okay I think the best shot
that mainstream Republicans to the
extent that they still exist have to
pull the extremists back to to reality
is by proving to them really showing
them that if you guys are are the
direction the party goes we lose I think
that that's the only way and even then I
think that if the Maga extremist Wing
just started losing badly I don't even
know that you would convert a lot of
those people I think a lot of those
people would give up and leave politics
so it's it's not it might not even
really be a conversion but I do think
that it's possible not with all of these
people but with some if Republicans
start taking more and more and more
losses as they already have but even
more
and then the mainstream Republicans say
it's because of you we need to come back
to something more approximating like
Mitt Romney or John McCain I think that
that's their best shot and even that may
not work I don't know
yeah that would be um great so
I I know there's been a lot of Articles
lately about Civil War and everything
what do you think our chances are of
ending up in something like that as of
right now so I never like to make these
long-term predictions the US will never
have a civil war we just don't know the
way I would assess it is I see the
chance of a civil war over the next five
years as extremely close to zero not
zero but extremely close to zero over
the next five years that's kind of where
I'm comfortable going right now
okay all right well thank you so much
for taking my call Pleasure Carolyn from
Utah great to hear from you